my classmates this year have definitely
become family not only if we spent a lot
of time studying and we're figuring out
accounting together but also you know
having tons of fun and challenging each
other that's probably the most important
thing with my classmates we've been able
to like really push each other to take
those risks and do the things we want to
do but we're scared to do and so I would
say they have held me the standards I
didn't realize I could be held to one of
the great things about the classes here
at the GSB is it's very participatory
and everyone is looking for what our
classmates are going to bring to the
discussion we're not just sitting there
listening to the professor where we're
actually learning from each other and so
it's really about thinking how I can
enhance the learning experience for my
cohort as well but I discovered from
working with them is that they all came
with certain leadership abilities and
their previous careers they accomplished
great things and just give having their
specific insights and in specific
industries was just opening for me in
many aspects so when I think about the
friends that I will have for the rest of
my life that have come from this program
and my group of friends who are very
much about social impact we talk about
social issues the volunteer events that
we go to what we're trying to do to make
our communities better and then my group
of friends who are more around industry
just because we have the same interest
around health care I've found them to be
some of my closest support in terms of
evaluating job opportunities the
healthcare space and when you have those
kind of friends who understand
healthcare but understand the importance
is of it it not only makes you show up
better for your job but also as a person
everyone is so accessible I can I feel
now that I can knock in any one store
and people will be happy to help out
with any issue I might have or just a
piece of advice or piece of information
I would be looking for my class of 80 we
have pretty much every field possible
represented from oil and gas to
technology to insurance to cars these
are all industries that I couldn't have
learned on my own or I would have had
had to spend five decades learning about
and in the last year from between IAT
class May
and all the professors I've worked with
and the hundreds of business cases I've
read I've learned so much about the
industries about the world about
business in a geopolitical context we we
often fantasize about creating the type
of community we have once we leave
campus because it's just been so special
the MSX community my classmates and the
cohort have really just made it special
and we've made really friends that will
be keeping for life
[Music]
you